good morning now on good day speaking
out her boss is an elected official
accused of murdering a journalist a
journalist who was investigating her
boss well we're going to hear the story
coming up plus and travel it boomed over
the summer and as you know that created
a slew of problems now the experts are
forecasting some holiday season woes and
are you a night owl are you an early
riser well new research shows how
staying up late can impact your health
maybe you're just a sleeper like
sleeping good day Las Vegas starts right
now now
this is good day Las Vegas live local
now 5 30 good morning that is one thing
I don't think anybody gets enough of is
sleep oh no have you ever met someone
who's like oh I'm fully breasted it's
ready you go to the office hey hey Marge
how was your night I had the best sleep
of my life great and if you and if they
do say that sure it's like that's great
you're just like yeah secretly so
jealous yeah I don't like you very much
yeah and who doesn't like sleeping I
mean right you know maybe kids children
yeah only they know they're excited
about everything the older you get the
more you like sleep I don't know what it
is
all right good sleeping weather now
especially if you sleep upstairs you can
open those windows and let the cool air
in if that doesn't bother you with
allergies beautiful shot looking
downtown we've got 70s just about Valley
Wide only one or two spots are trying to
fight in some 60s this morning we're not
quite as cool as we were yesterday but
oh so close air is still pretty dry out
there and we've got some southerly
breezes but overall those winds have
calmed down quite a bit they were bumpy
again yesterday afternoon we hit those
mid 90s for highs and had those
southerly winds 80 degrees back
mid-morning plenty of good Sunshine
coming our way again today today should
really be a perfect repeat of Monday
upper 80's by noon good sunshine in
those southerly breezes picking up again
we'll look for them to be generally up
to about 25 miles an hour highs in the
mid 90s this afternoon so just really a
couple of degrees above normal should be
down to about 93 for the afternoon High
we're getting ready to close out summer
we'll see how the temperatures cooperate
5 32 hopefully everybody's cooperating
on the roads so far so good the freeways
are crash free there is one crash on the
access ramp from Valley View get onto
the 95. keep an eye out for that one
meantime there is a crash right in front
of Palo station just a little bit east
of there at Rancho and it is affecting
folks trying to get on or off the 15. so
a couple of minutes ago I had one of the
cars that was wrapped around this
utility pole on the back of a pickup
truck but this is Rancho kind of tough
getting onto Sahara eastbound Sahara
you're doing all right take a live look
here they're making some progress so
eastbound as you got to squeeze over to
the left folks who are westbound trying
to get onto the South 15. it's doable
just be very careful through there on
Sahara in front of Palace Station all
right let's head on down to the Las
Vegas Strip where preparations are
underway for the Las Vegas Aces parade
that short little Parade from Caesars
across Flamingo to the Bellagio
Fountains we're told that there are
going to be some lane closures if you
don't have business on the Strip other
than going to the parade you probably
should avoid it but we'll be keeping an
eye on it for you with Candace Charles
with the live report coming up in just a
few minutes John hither Nate we
appreciate that later this morning Clark
County public administrator Rob Tellis
is expected in court again they elected
official accused of murdering review
journal investigative reporter Jeff
Garman Garman wrote several stories
highlighting issues within the public
administrator's office office a source
for his stories was tell us his
assistant Rita Reed who you just saw on
camera Reed spoke with eight news now
investigator Vanessa Murphy about what
she hopes to see in court this morning
what would it mean for you if he is able
to post bond
be frightening can be frightening
tell us the Clark County public
administrator is accused of murdering
review journal investigative reporter
Jeff gearman he actually listened Reed
is the assistant public administrator
she and other employees worked with
gearman to expose problems under the
leadership of Telus Reid ran against
teles and beat him in the Democratic
primary she faces a republican to win
the seat in November our goal was to get
our office back on track she says
complaints to the county and Union about
Telus bullying employees went nowhere he
became more emboldened in his behavior
and treatment and she saw a side to tell
us which she says most people haven't I
saw tremendous rage there were several
incidences where he came into my office
in a rage
and I and the circumstances didn't
warrant that at all when the work
environment continued to be toxic you're
working on pins and needles and you hear
footsteps coming in and so you tense up
she says she and her co-workers turned
to German they exposed a possible
inappropriate relationship with a
subordinate Telus made social media
posts critical of the stories and then
on September 3rd gearman was found
stabbed to death outside his home did
you suspect Rob immediately immediately
immediately Metro Police say DNA found
underneath gearman's Nails matches Telus
and the elected officials SUV shoes and
clothing are also tied to the scene you
ever feel a physical threat from him
there I was very intimidated I think
many people were she says she and
gearman told each other to be safe but
she never imagined his work would cost
him his life Jeff was
so amazing for us and for our department
and to this community and we will
forever be grateful in Las Vegas Vanessa
Murphy 8 News Now
search and rescue crews found the body
of missing hiker Rock Stanley Stanley
went missing after a morning hike
Saturday August 23rd we spoke with Red
Rock search and rescue they tell us 12
searches totaling more than 1400
man-hours went into finding Stanley for
them offering the family closure is a
big deal
super important to get answers for the
family so that they're not sitting there
for months and years waiting and
wondering what happened to their loved
one and it allows them to be to begin
the grieving process and to to continue
on with life Craig McVeigh told us that
Stanley was found at the bottom of a
steep slope they're unsure of how he
died but police say foul play was not a
factor 5 37 on a Tuesday morning this
morning encouraging science for a metro
police officer injured in this crash
earlier in September officer Garen
Santos was hit by a suspected drunk
driver as he headed to another DUI
incident he's now been through several
surgeries here you see him leaving UMC I
believe as you see fellow officers gave
officer santosis touching send-off late
last week Metro say he is now in an
Inpatient Rehab Facility wishing the
best there's a brand new bridge in the
East Valley stretching over East Desert
and across the Las Vegas wash
Commissioners as you can see there they
say it's going to improve access to
us-95 and eventually add another
connection to Henderson we've been
trying to improve transportation in the
East Valley for a long time turning
pennies into a million dollars well that
reality came true for this fella who was
playing penny slots over at Circa you
only wanted to be identified as Mark he
hit the jackpot playing one of those
Buffalo Diamond machines the jackpot
more than one and a quarter million
dollars if I had that one that much
money my smile might be a little bit
bigger but not by much like hurting your
face excited pennies to million yeah
quick take the pictures I can go to the
bank hurry up I'm running out of here
all right it's 5 30 in here
comes Vegas are you a night owl or are
you an early bird
question new research showing just hang
up late could impact your health and
we're celebrating the Las Vegas Aces
WNBA Champions they have a parade today
could affect your commute later on this
afternoon we'll talk about that coming
up first here's sharing the weather and
we're celebrating some pretty nice
weather too barely getting a little
early light out there not much will stay
pretty clear low 70s through the morning
upper 70's by 9 A.M into the 80s we go
at the noon hour and Here Come Those
southerly breezes back they'll be back
all through the afternoon and even
during the aces parade later this
afternoon mid 90s for your Tuesday it
will be warm and somewhat windy we'll
look to stay somewhat warm through the
evening hours we've got to dip in the
temperatures before maybe triple digits
return it's all in your most accurate
forecast after the break room